previously in the you 12 advanced course
I don't have like that trailer voice to
read this kind of thing I want you to
think back to when we were doing areas
under curves right at the start and we
looked at how you can actually do some
pretty interesting looking areas even
ones you're not supposed to be able to
do and this was this was one of them
right I said hey look you've got this y
equals log X curve which we're not
supposed to be able to know how to
integrate but we can still work out the
area if you recall we did this little
trick we said hey you can work out this
area over to the y-axis and then
subtract that from the bigger rectangle
that encloses both of them so I'll come
to your question shortly I will I will
do any of the questions that you have
and but I will get started with the
lesson first and then we'll come to any
issues that you need clarification with
okay so the thing that I wanted to call
your attention to was I just kind of
offhandedly said this is a function that
you're not supposed to be able to
integrate and those of you who have a
keen memory might recall that I said
yeah but if you are an extension to
student and those people who are
learning for unit maths all that fancy
stuff they actually can integrate this
now I'm just gonna quickly show you not
for the purposes of copying it down but
just to explain to you that how it's
actually done this is what it looks like
if you try and actually use those fancy
techniques this is what the working will
actually pan out to be some of you as
you look through it you might say yeah I
actually understand a fair bit of that
this by the way this technique that's
being used here this is a simplified way
of using a technique called integration
by parts you guys know how there's the
chain rule learning is the reverse chain
rule well there's a product rule and
then this is what we would call the
reverse product rule now it's not
something that we learn to mix in the
normal Advanced Course because it's
quite fancy and difficult but the reason
why I am drawing your attention back to
this is that even though an extension to
student can integrate y equals log X
because they have all this other fancy
knowledge there's some stuff that no
matter how you know advanced you are no
matter what course you're doing no
matter if you're like the university
level mathematician or some way that
they just can't be integrated in the way
that we've been talking about you
can't find what we call an elementary
primitive function so here's an example
right this function here it looks
disgusting right it looks terrible and
if you try to integrate if you hand this
to some mathematician and we've actually
proved that it can't be done you cannot
find a primitive function for this guy
it's literally impossible now you might
not be surprised to see that because
you're like yeah it's a gross looking
function right but even functions that
look much less intimidating like this
this also this second function here e to
the negative x squared just can't be
integrated which is surprising when you
look at what the function is is actually
a famous function it's called the
Gaussian function it's really important
in statistics which we're going to
return to again later on even though
this function looks nice and neat and
tidy and not complicated at all again
you can't integrate it and it just gets
worse and worse when you have a look at
like the real world and when you look at
physical situations now this equation
here which is probably gonna make your
head hurt even when you look at it it's
a famous equation the navier-stokes
equation because it relates to fluids
and how they move around so for example
if you're trying to understand the
weather right that's fluids that are
moving air viscosity all the rest that's
what this equation tells you it's just a
garbled mess you cannot integrate this
and get something nice and simple at the
end
so therefore what we're gonna deal with
today is a piece of knowledge and a
skill that will help us deal with all
these weird gross looking functions that
apparently you can't integrate we can
still find out areas under curves at
least approximately and that's going to
be what we develop using this rule that
I'm going to show you now I want to
introduce it again I want to call your
mind back to our very first lesson on
integration where we talked about areas
under curves and you might remember mrs.
Lee's did a bit of a history lesson for
us right and she talked about Isaac
Newton and this guy called Gottfried
Leibniz and basically their idea was
this right you can approximate the area
under a curve using rectangles and if
your rectangles are thin enough small
enough you can get as close to the area
as you like in fact you can get
precisely the area
we're going to employ a trick just like
that but we're going to use a better
shape and you might have gotten a clue
for this if you were on time and you saw
the part of a website that I showed you
guys before we're not going to use
rectangles we're gonna use trapeziums
trapeziums it turns out I'm much better
because you can see they don't have
those all the flat edges we can bend
them around into nice neat uh shapes
that allow us to approximate the area
and to cave on welcome memories so let's
have a go at this right it says the
trapezoidal rule and I'm gonna give you
an example function which we can
integrate I'm going to use this example
even though we know how to integrate it
so that we can actually get an
approximation for what's going on all
right so let's have a go at this x
squared you can see on the right hand
side here I have highlighted a part of
the graph an area under the curve and
it's going to be I'm starting here at 1
and ending over here at 3 so let's go
ahead and let's integrate this to find
the area area equals I am actually going
to work out this area precisely using
integration and then we're going to work
out how to put trapeziums onto this so
that we can approximate the area and I'm
gonna use that formula the trapezoidal
rule in the case of areas which I can't
do my integration so that's what the
integral my lower boundary is going to
start over here at 1 so I'm going to
integrate from 1 all the way up to my
upper boundary which is 3 and I'm gonna
get x squared DX over here now this is
pretty simple right this is actually
probably a bit of a relief after all the
questions we've been doing recently
which were more complicated than this
let's go ahead and just integrate it
together I'm going to get X cubed on 3
I'm gonna integrate from 1 to 3 and now
I'm ready to substitute in these are
boundaries so let's see here 3 cubed on
3 that's 27 on 3 and then 1 cubed on 3
is 1 over 3 so that's 9 take away 1/3 so
I'm getting 8 and 2/3 ok let's have a
look
are you happy with my working there's a
degree with you give me a thumbs up if
you're okay with that if you're
following and if my numbers look right
to you
fantastic thanks Yvonne and Abby much
appreciated okay